I would give a first generation low
income student in high school the advice,
Just relax.
You're going to be okay
and you're going to end up
where you're supposed to be.
For a lot of FGLI students.
Something that comes up is imposter
syndrome.
Really practice in
building self confidence
and really believing in yourself,
knowing that you are just as capable.
My best advice is to just be yourself.
There's really no mold
that we want you to fit into.
We're looking for people
who are authentic.
I would say apply through QuestBridge.
I found the QuestBridge application
was really a valuable tool for me
because it allowed me to present my story
and who I am
more than just, you know, what
I've done academically.
Look for what you're going
to bring to the community here at Yale
and how it's going to serve you
just as well as you're going to serve it.
Focusing on that rather than making
yourself into somebody that you're not
is definitely the right way to go.